(upbeat music)
- Hello.
- Hello Kelly.
- You are very funny. Meet Utkarsh.
- Yes I know, I watched your whole thing.
You have so many projects
that I'm tired listening to his jobs.
(Kelly laughing)
- You work hard for the money.
Working hard for the money.
- Yeah. Good for you.
- So wait, is it true that your parents
they brought a tour bus of
people to your show once?
- Yeah. For better or worse.
I was in Sarasota
which is where a lot of
old people in Florida are.
I mean, it's not all old people.
Somebody has to run things.
(laughing)
There are young people down there,
but they're very busy,
taking care of this entire
community of cocoon.
It's like cocoon.
- Oh my God, I love cocoon.
- I did too and it really happens
at my mom and dad's golf course
at 8:00 AM boom, it is cocoon.
There's thousands of old people,
they're organized.
- Living their best life.
- And they're chop chop.
- (laughing) They're organized.
- They've had lasagna and
breakfast and you know.
- It's all on military time.
- Oh my. They're so into it, right?
But I did a show there
at some theater thing
and my dad goes, well, one of the gals
at the golf course got a tour bus,
so we'll just be rocking up front.
Well, there was 60 of them in it.
And then they showed up and
some security guard goes,
yo you got a mama named Vicky?
And I went, yeah. I knew
this wasn't gonna be good.
(laughing)
He goes, well, her and
your dad and a bunch
of other people forgot their
identification and VAX cards.
I'm like, how did you
leave the house with no ID?
And my dad goes, we're so old,
nobody asks for it anymore.
(laughing)
I'm like okay. So then he, they come in,
we got him in and then he said,
is there any way you can come on the bus?
And you know, I go, you want
me to go do my act on the bus?
You just saw it.
He goes, you got another
10 minutes in ya, come on.
So I went out and did comedy on the bus.
- That's nice.
- But just to make 'em feel
bad for forgetting their stuff,
I go, since you guys didn't show up
with your correct paperwork,
I'm gonna make you count off
like you're in grade school.
And if there's not 60 of you,
if there's one crazy old lady
in the bathroom, she's getting locked in.
(laughing)
I'm not going to find your friends.
They're here or they're not.
- Well your special is called
Kathleen Madigan Hunting Bigfoot.
So why, are you hunting for Bigfoot?
- No, I'm not actively hunting.
- It would've been a more
fun answer if you said yes.
- Yes, No, I, there was a comedian who was
and then I saw how intense it got
and I'm like, yeah, I don't need to be.
- Oh, like he was real about it.
- He was for real.
Like there were books
and then I expressed a
little bit of interest.
Huge error. Don't do that.
Don't do that with an enthusiast.
Then they think you're on board.
I'm like, oh, I didn't mean all that.
I just meant I think it's out there.
There's a creature, ah.
Somewhere in Washington.
I don't wanna go look for it. I don't.
But me and another comedian
had to drive through
like Oregon and Washington
and I was talking to him about
what would we do if we hit one?
Like it's worth millions of dollars.
So if you hit one.
- Oh, like if you accidentally
hit it with your car?
- Yeah. Because of Covid,
they were coming into town.
Well, not Bigfoots, but you know,
animals were coming into town
and I was like what if we
hit it, like we need a plan.
So then that's what I call my special.
It's all about my plan of if you hit one
what you should do and
what you should not do.
- Okay. I'm thinking if you hit
what is supposed to be a
Bigfoot, like something large,
you might die.
- Well, there's two scenarios.
You've hit it and it's injured.
Now it's under the wheel well.
Just (mimicking Bigfoot)
it's really angry.
- [Kelly] Leave it there.
- That's terrible. Right.
Try to get off the, get your
rental car off of it and leave.
Then the other one is
it's dead. But now what?
What if there's another one
around, like its partner.
- You don't know if they move in packs.
- [Kathleen] Or its kid? We don't know.
- We don't know if they move in packs.
- [Kathleen] So far it's fictional.
- [Utkarsh] That's terrifying.
- You don't know what it would do, but,
so anyway, that's what-
- I keep thinking Harry
and the Hendersons.
You remember that? Oh my gosh.
- All I see is Harry right now.
- I love that car.
- What would you do? I don't know.
You need to think about it.
- If it's under the car
and it's a rental car
now do I have insurance?
Like, have I paid for the insurance?
(laughing)
- [Kathleen] Well, that depends.
- This is an old person response.
(laughing)
This is a 39-
- How much am I gonna tell him the truth?
But then there's all that
hair, they're gonna know.
Like you can't. It's like a crime scene.
You can't clean it up
that easily. It's hairy.
(laughing)
I mean, I just picture like
red, brown hair everywhere
in the wheel well and
Avis won't understand.
They don't care.
- You're just gonna have to pay for it.
- Right. I take it back and
they're just gonna write
check, check, she ruined that.
She ruined that. She ruined that.
- Also, found Bigfoot.
Yeah, I don't think they'd care.